downtown Los Angeles people head here to
work shop and eat there's plenty of food
to be had
including this bad boy meet the
bacon-wrapped hot dog top it with
anything you like and you've got
yourself one of LA's proudest
gastronomical traditions it tastes so
good and it's so bad for you
you might think it's illegal actually it
is welcome to the underground world of
black market
bacon dogs okay it's not really
underground you see food carts like this
all over the place and there's bigger
ones too some vendors will sell you an
illegal bacon dog but hardly any we'll
talk about it she doesn't want to talk
the owner of this cart wouldn't talk but
she responded to our questions through
one of her customers bobby yellow two
weeks ago somebody spoke to the
somebody in the news and that's why they
were harassed they're trying to get rid
of them and who is trying to get rid of
them on the health department the vendor
tells fabiella that the Health
Department has been cracking down on
bacon dog sellers how they've been
arrested on the food is basically thrown
in the trash for everything they have
they throw it in the trash
we saw it ourselves the cops confiscated
these dogs the dogs were done
you
and then the carts tossed into the
garbage truck now why in the world would
officials want to mess with something
that's so delicious it all starts with
the salty strip that wraps around the
hotdog though I'm baking miss alline
Elizabeth Palacios is one of the few
vendors willing to speak publicly
I used to that before but Hilda but dr.
Mendelsohn allowed that she's been
selling bacon dogs and other food for
about 20 years she pays taxes and is
required to have three different kinds
of permits city permits held apartment
permits and Barnacle ization permanent
she's used the money she's made to raise
her daughter buy a car and a house no I
love to sell this is my life I like to
be with customer to talk to them I feel
proud of myself but with run-ins with
the health department and police
officers palacios worries about the
future
she says she loses business if she
doesn't give customers the bacon they
demand they one thinking they want the
butter with bacon it just gives it like
it I'm just just extra extra taste the
crispiness of the baked in it just the
flavors together is just wonderful bacon
is a potential hazardous food Terrence
Powell of the LA County Health
Department potentially hazardous foods
by definition are those foods that if
not kept within certain limits whether
it be temperature or or pH control
acidity would allow for the growth of
harmful bacteria that would get you sick
so how many people are getting sick from
these bacon dogs that's kind of a
nebulous number we don't know how many
cases of food sickness come from eating
out versus eating at home so no one
really knows if these dogs are dangerous
but Powell says customers expect food to
be safe that they're not going to be
locked up in the restroom at home
because they ain't a hot dog that was
improperly cooked or improperly stored
well said Terrence our cameraman Alex
gravely agreed to an experiment that
would test the bacon dogs effect on the
human body
actually Alex was walking down dogs long
before we aimed the cameras out but
we'll still give him credit for
advancing science well check on Alex
later gee I hope he's okay but Powell
says the Palacios can sidestep this
controversy and sell bacon dogs legally
how get rid of her old cart and buy a
sleek new one like this that comes with
new features like a three compartment
sink so that you can wash rinse and
sanitize any of the equipment that's
being used utensils in the light the new
car clothes is like 26 thousand how I
can afford it the new cart is about five
times as expensive as the cart Palacios
has now but if she sells baking dogs
without it she faces the inevitable
stiff consequences it's a thousand
dollars or six months in jail and we
will summarily take individuals to court
if they violate the law they took
Palacios to court about a year ago after
catching her cooking bacon dolls at the
pay a lawyer the judge sentenced her to
45 days in jail what's up black date for
me meanwhile alex is still downing dogs
with no ill effects and we didn't find
anyone who has gotten sick from bacon
dogs non-aggressive
I never come in sick and and I think the
people that sells hot dogs really
helping us we are in the business of
preventing people from getting sick and
we will do that of course it is possible
that the bacon hotdogs might have made
some people sick but in addition to what
might have happened maybe shouldn't we
also consider what we know for sure is
happening to people like Elizabeth
Palacio so all that money get me behind
my bills and right now Brooke I'm a
steal Brooke almost one year one year
after getting busted she's still deep in
debt from paying attorneys fees and
fines and because she was unable to work
for 45 days it is
really really amazing that is over 12
months I've been laying on my mortgage
now she worries that she'll lose her
house and points to the vendors with the
tiny carts they do a lot of more money
than I do she says if she doesn't sell
bacon dogs customers will buy from them
and he don't have to be Ben Bernanke to
know that she's right and they said you
have bacon and I said no he says all
thank you and they quote with what
whoever had bacon
she loses money and the goal of
protecting consumers doesn't turn out
the way officials wanted shocked because
unlike Elizabeth these vendors aren't
licensed at all they don't care about of
your team and if you don't have license
if you don't have a license to handle
the food they just want the bacon that's
right Elizabeth they just want the bacon
for recent TV
I'm drew Carey
you